we've got some breaking news that just
came out and it actually
centers around the daily wire and it
will have effects for basically
everybody in this country
the biden administration has just
formalized its
vaccine mandate rule you remember they
announced it months ago but that was
basically a press release
we didn't know when it was going to go
into effect what the role is going to be
they just dropped a 490 page rule
this will require
every company with more than 100
employees
to force their employees to take the
fouchy algae to to violate either their
religious con conscience possibly their
medical prunins their own personal
medical decisions or they're basically
threatening these businesses with with
putting them out of business
the daily wire is suing the biden
administration we have just moments ago
filed a lawsuit uh this has gone in the
u.s court of appeals for the sixth
circuit we are absolutely not going to
comply i will tell you that this legal
fight that we have just launched is
going to be extremely expensive uh
we we don't care we're willing to risk
it we've built a very powerful machine
here we've built it thanks to you we do
need your support now we need your
support now more than ever before if you
want to be in the fight
if you if this matters to you if you
don't think that the biden
administration should be able to use
this ridiculous workaround because they
basically admitted they don't have the
authority the authority to do this joe
biden said on the campaign trail he
wasn't going to be pushing vaccine
mandates because it was unpopular and
almost certainly unconstitutional so
what he did was this
bizarre byzantine work around through
the occupational safety and health
administration to get private businesses
to do their dirty work for them and they
know they're probably going to lose this
in court so they just want to force you
to all get it before the courts rule
against them this is a very very
difficult very expensive fight it is
thug tactics from a thug crooked
administration we're not going to take
it lying down but we we do need your
support now more than ever if you want
to be in the fight with us
i strongly suggest you do this is the
time to stand up people go to
dailywire.com subscribe use code do not
comply jeremy boring has this to say
about it
again this is just coming out from the
press release the daily wire will not
comply with president biden's tyrannical
vaccine mandate we are suing the biden
administration to put a stop to their
gross overreach by president biden the
federal government social media and the
establishment media have conspired to
rob americans of their freedoms in the
name of public health they have broken
faith with the american people through
conflicting messaging false information
and by suppressing data and perspectives
with which they disagree
we are working with harmeet dillon you
may know hermet dillon very very
important very good lawyer in this
country she says quote the federal
government lacks the legal authority to
compel private employers to play the
role of vaccine or coveted police lack
the police power to force private
employees to undergo medical treatment
and may not ignore constitutional limits
on its ability to regulate every aspect
of our lives
she goes on the biden administration's
attempt to impose this unprecedented and
unlawful federal medical mandate on the
u.s workforce without considering the
public's views as arbitrary capricious
unsupported by the evidence and would
produce a willfully ignorant rule
willful ignorance would seem to be
the
the theme for the biden administration
so right now i mean just this rule in g
will affect
80 million workers
or more
very possibly more than that the biden
administration
is is
not even pushing a constitutionally
sound rule so much as they are
attempting to intimidate you to take
a
shot
an experimental shot you know a shot
that was just developed not that long
ago
even against your own judgment
for a virus that for the vast majority
of people does not pose a particularly
grave
threat this is it folks you know
there's there is an expression that i
really hate but it comes up a lot and
the squishes always bring it up they say
do you really want to die on this hill
oh come on you really want to die on
this hill this come on just give the
left whatever they want and then we'll
die on the next hill you know if you
don't stand up on a hill eventually you
run out of hills to fight on and then
it's over and then the battle's over and
the fight's over and so we made it very
clear from the moment that the biden
administration announced they were going
to do this
that we're not going to stand for it
we are not going to go down without a
fight
we're very fortunate that we've built a
strong platform here we have built a
strong platform with a strong voice that
is posing a real threat to the biden
administration and to the
liberal ruling class more broadly
and so we're going to use it
and it's not going to be easy and i'm i
understand there are going to be a lot
of companies that just kind of go along
with it they just don't want to have to
deal with it okay but we really believe
this is the fight this is the kind of
thing that we built this company for
okay and if we don't stand up here we're
not going to stand up for anything
so we're going to do that we're going to
put ourselves on the line and we're
going to lead the fight and we're going
to sue the biden administration and
we're going to take these jerks and
crooks and bullies and thugs to court
and we're going to take it as far as it
needs to go and we need
your support dailywire.com
subscribe code
do not comply do not let this moment
pass without fighting back
do not
tell your grandkids someday ah where was
i during that big fight when the medical
technocratic liberal tyranny finally
quashed the last little bit of freedom
and tradition we had in this country oh
well i was
cowering in a corner don't cower in a
quarter stand with us
fight it we appreciate your support
[Music]
[Music]
you